foreign
I think we should start we have a few
people
joining this round table on maximizing
the use of proteomics data so I would
like to welcome everyone both in the
audience as well as
the panelists and I suggest we start by
a quick round of introductions of the
panel
um and I'll call upon the panelists who
maybe in two words simply just say hello
and and tell us who they are my name is
Bernard Crystal I'm I have the chair of
proteomics at the Techno University of
Munich and I'm I have the pleasure to
sort of host that round table so but if
we go around the panelists are in no
particular order I'll start with Lauren
hello Lauren hi
um I'm Lauren I'm uh trying to finish my
PhD
um I work at MIT enforce whites group
um at the Koch Institute for Integrative
cancer research I guess the pandemic has
has slowed down my degree progress a
little bit
um but I'm excited to to be here with
you all today and uh to chat yeah
all right Nicola
hello my name is Nicola teneta I'm
associate professor of energy and
Discovery in Oxford so my group is
mostly interested in the sequencing of
MHC Associated peptides and yes I look
forward to the discussions
hello everybody my name is
in Stockholm Sweden I have a chair in
proteomics in cairolinsky Institute
and my lab is doing cancer proteomics
both on Discovery and more sort of
clinical validation side
also part of the national facility and
in proteomics
how's your day
oh
learned and so it's in Sweden in the
southern part from Jana and so we are in
in the hospital in the clinical area
working on on melanoma cancer so we're
interested in the drug impact and the
development of of the disease of all
from a pathological point of view moving
towards the link to to molecular
pathology
lining in proteomics
okay and Lucas
hello everybody my name is Lucas writer
my background is in Biochemistry
proteomics and I'm CTO at diagnosis
which is a proteomics company in
Switzerland
well hello everybody
okay so now we've done introductions I
think I haven't missed anyone
um
so the idea would be of this round table
that would discuss and debate questions
that may come from the audience I can't
see any uh yet at the moment but I'm
encouraging everyone to shoot their
questions that they've always had never
dare to ask
um to our highly knowledgeable panelists
that span everything from getting a
sample squeezing it through a mass
spectrometer and making sense of the
data in the end
but maybe to to sort of set the stage a
bit and get the the debate going I've
shared a few
questions with the panelists ahead of
time and
I'm maybe going to put them a little
under pressure now but you've all seen
them so you all had at least one minute
to think about them uh but given that
this session also the scientific session
had a focus on cancer will stay within
there
and one of the questions
um that I actually get asked quite a few
times is what can we actually reasonably
expect to learn from proteoms of tumoris
sections or biopsies or body fluids of
cancer patients or some model either be
it in vitro and Vivo model of cancer and
it would be great if one of you guys
would take have the courage to in one
way to provide an answer to a b and c
foreign
so I think that the the a either tumor
uh section biopsy I would uh say that um
I mean
one word it's a long one though
molecular phenotype I think that's what
we can expect okay and in a body fluids
I would go for uh immune state
systemic immune State and in the model
systems
I would pick this is really not one
words but the sort of combination
treatment targets
okay anyone else want to offer something
here
yes please
um very interesting start and I think
for my perspective
for a tumor receptions
um to my mind comes antigens targetable
antigens maybe two words to be cancer
patient body fluids I would say
biomarkers
reaction to therapy we can look at that
environment animal in different models
of cancer I would
maybe be less optimistic I think
specifically in immunotherapy fields I
see
um
well some some limitations in animal
models and I would say that it is a well
that's not a word is it so I
um I think we can learn combination
therapy is maybe it is you actually you
actually said nothing so in a one word
you actually said nothing
any other one word answers
no life is more yeah I could go in
line with my talk so for for cancerous
tissue it would be therapeutic targets
essentially so that's what I present in
my talk
and for plasma or biofluids it would be
prognostic markers
and nothing from the models okay all
right um yeah you have something to
offer
no I I I would uh
I would go against you Bernard and I
would turn to question these questions
around and I think that what is actually
the most important is the clinical
material at hand
I mean these six the the parts relating
to whether you're gonna do in animal
models or or tumors or whatever it all
comes down that you actually have a
clear view on what you're working with
and also that you have an understanding
of what you're addressing
in the objective of the study and that
you also have a sort of a broad team
that is able to take it on because the
the readouts from whatever you get I
mean looking back 5 10 or whatever
number of years I think this has been
the the shortcoming
so I actually think that in order to to
reach all these goals with one word or
several words I don't think I I think
you really need to have an absolute
Cutting Edge linked to high high quality
materials in studies in order to provide
value so here's a question then to the
panelists from me I mean the good um of
course making good points by everyone
but maybe starting really with the
samples and what they are
um what's your in your experience or in
your projects what's your actual reality
are you working with the Pathologists
that often are also responsible for the
biobangs or are you working with the
clinicians that that takes out stuff
from patients and so happens to be
interested and therefore things uh one
should look at the material that they
cut out or
um so what's the what's the setup in in
your experience in your environments
so you mean alone here right yeah loon
for example it's very clear that I'm
enjoying you're also responsible for bio
for biobanking have been for a long time
so
um clearly you are uh right there but in
Stockholm for example how does how is it
done well I think that we are in a
fortunate position since uh since um
since we are heading or I am heading the
clinical uh programs facility at the
hospital side
so we are actually uh I we have um I
mean I have one pathologist in the
facility working with this type of
things and uh and we can we can also
influence the the
the standard operation procedures for
the material sampling I mean to uh in uh
I mean in a crazy extent and sometimes
we have for example have uh we have
taken blood sample on the vein that is
coming out of the tumor during the
operation in order to enrich the tissue
in its biomarkers
but I mean of course that's not the uh
that's a discovery set but in a clinical
set you then I mean you need to fall
back into something that is done in the
clinical routine if you want to do a
multi-center trial or something but I
think that we we need to we need to
think both aspects I mean what is the
best Discovery set and then what is the
actual
uh implementation set where you can
actually do a multi-center study or even
Venture towards the clinical routine
that says a completely different uh type
of
material flows
[Music]
in Oxford I mean given I mean you're
doing immunopeptidomis which is let's
say different from cutting out solid
tumors for example but um still what's
sort of your
gateway to the a good sample or
well-controlled study so we are really
trying to work with the Pathologists and
with the clinicians to try and get tumor
receptions because we think that's the
most relevant material to work with at
least for
um cancer cancer antigen Discovery and
we we have a couple of consortiums set
up around that where we are really
trying to set up a clinical protocol and
then work with receiving the correct
samples it is challenging and it takes
time I mean that's that's from our
perspective
um the the limitations there so yes we
are in the process to have these
conversations but it is in my experience
very difficult to implement novel ways
of collecting tissue and and then
getting it into the lab and analyzing it
so it can take years and we we are
trying on several different levels in
several different indications to to
collect such tissue now and any
suggestions how we can make it better
from any site would would really help so
we we for for us it's it's the
limitation to get really good samples
and um yeah I mean it directly links to
what Jerry was saying of course and but
maybe I'll rephrase then perhaps my
question type of number one which of
course I provocatively just put out and
expected some challenge to it but um so
then the the question would be
um what are we talking about in clinical
proteomics today
do we do we think everybody's still
doing Discovery is there are there
actually people who are trying to
um make a difference already for
treatment decisions or are we monitoring
biomarkers longitudinally for samples
that we can collect and have in biobanks
but don't really that are no longer
relevant for the actual person so where
where do you think the field kind of
sits and of course again is No not a one
answer to all this um because people are
working in all those angles but if one
were to look across the board
where do you think the field still sort
of sits mostly Discovery or
translational or actual clinical care
I mean we we often work together with
people in drug development that can be
all stages of drug development so
our customs and collaborators they they
came into early research to develop
normal drugs or it can be annual models
or it can be your product into trials so
that's obviously one big part
that is an application
yeah maybe I answered that also from
from our perspective
so we we work um with a number of
different biotechs in order to drive the
antigens that we discover in the samples
forward and ultimately I I see the value
of biobanks really in in in in having
large cohorts available that can be
interrogated for common targets so that
that that can be progressed in into the
clinic and so it is I think our work
specifically is quite translational and
both
um and we are we're maybe moving a bit
away from the more personalized
approaches where specific tumors are
analyzed and then specific medicines
developed
um more towards them a broader approach
and and
um searching for common antigens and I
think both
um smaller chords and and the biobank
boards are really crucial to to pursue
such work well maybe the direct question
to that uh what do you think is
specifically the the value that
proteomics brings here because one could
argue you could just sequence the hell
out of all these biobank materials if
you're looking for common
common things let's say mutations that
might be presented on the surface of a
cell and therefore might be good good
targets to go after what do you think
specifically the the proteomic angle is
here well proteomics tells us exactly
what is being
um what is in the cell what what is in
the tumor cell and what's different from
a healthy cell so you can't really get
that information from genomics
um data and also not really from
transcriptonic data you might know what
is what is expressed but what you really
need to know if you want to Target a
tumor
um is is what is what what are the
antigens presented on the surface for
example or what are the proteins
expressed and are there surface proteins
that we can Target and proteomics of
course
um also gives us the opportunity to look
for
responses in in biofluids which which is
really difficult to do with with other
means so for me the value really is that
we can with I mean so if I mean my
specific field is immuno peptidomics of
course so what we can say is is you know
what what are the so even if you have
transcriptomics data but you already
know their specific trans transcripts
coming up in the tumors we can say well
those transcripts are presented on the
surface and they are targetable which is
a step further to really refine the
targets that you do want to progress in
into the into the clinic in my opinion
so I I see it's a very very important
value
they are in in proteomics technology but
also looking at at patients and the
response and trying to understand why
for example certain approaches don't
work or work only in certain individuals
now as we've learned from from Janice
talk earlier is that that you know you
can you can really decipher
um if you have immuno if you do
immunotherapy for example you can try
and decipher why does it only work in a
certain cohort of patients and not in
others and that will really guide our
way to to functional novel Therapeutics
in in the future I think
okay
um so um one of the things that I mean
the title of Our Round Table is actually
maximizing the use of proteomic data so
I guess we might all have
um
an opinion about for what it means for
ourselves but maybe still I'll pose my
second question which is related to this
and again which is something that at
least in my lab is debated a lot and it
the answers of course will be graded and
different
um
but proteomics is still quite a sort of
costly technology in the sense that you
have to get great samples and run them
down expensive equipment and it takes
time to look at the data so one question
that comes up frequently is how deep a
proteome do we actually have to generate
in order to learn something a be it in
tissue speed in fluid speed in the
models and again
it's deeply related to the question
we're trying to
to answer or ask first of all and and
then answer hopefully and I I think it's
an impossible question in a sense but I
want to get your take on it because
we've we are debating this many many
times and it's very hard to say ahead of
time often we are surprised by how
shallow a proteome would have given us
an answer and sometimes we are wondering
that even a super deep proteome hasn't
given us an answer
um
but technology wise it may not always be
necessary to dig 10 000 proteins into a
sample or trying to get 500 proteins in
a fluids or what what do you think I
mean again it's totally fine to argue
completely from your own perspectives
um but as I said this is a question that
is asked a lot in my team or at least I
ask it a lot
because it makes a difference if you
have to go very deep then you don't do
so many and if you can go shallow you
can do many
yeah
any experience from your end
yeah I can say something about that so
if you're talking about tissue for
instance and again I can make the
connection to the to what I showed about
Target identification so many targets
are rather lower abundance for instance
kinases
and if you want to get insight into the
mechanisms of the action of drugs or if
you want to find normal targets then
obviously more sensitivity helps a lot
so I would say from this perspective it
would be nice if you could see the full
expressed protein tissue
and if you're talking about fire fluids
what I find a really interesting
hypothesis is that some people say that
in body fluids on plasma you can
actually find all the urine proteins
that are expressed I mean this may be
true or maybe not true but I think it's
at least plausible that that's the case
and
in many known biomarkers they are rather
low bonds such as troponin for instance
and I would say the chances always
increase to find more specific
biomarkers the more
then you create your head as long as the
connotation is really high quality of
course
well I can give you a color around this
not of course also to challenge this but
one of the most important protein
biomarkers is of course human theorem
albumin
and it happens to be by far the most
abundant protein in a body fluid and if
you have too little of it your liver
doesn't work and that's that has is of
great predictive value
um as a biomarker or C-reactive protein
it's not hard to find it may not be very
specific in terms of which exact
effective fat infection you have but
something is switched on and so this is
this is sort of why I'm posing the
question the way I do
um sometimes it's surprising perhaps how
how little one has to know in order to
come to a conclusion on a certain
question and the human theorem argument
of course maybe being a most extreme
case but um
proteins are not informative not at all
so
they are certainly also very informative
maybe I can comment also on this uh
starting from the since people are not
commenting the in vitro and model system
studies there I think that
um that we really need to I've written
uh three answers just in a sort of
provocative way I think that we should
go for 14 000 proteins in the model
systems five in biopsies and thousand
five thousand in biopsies and thousand
in plasma but what I think is really
frustrating in in proteomics literature
is that the model system studies can be
really shallow sometimes and I mean if
you are going to do a model system
studies you really need to understand
the protein biology and that's not Gene
Centric it can be proteins Centric you
need to add ptms protein variants and so
on
but in the clinical uh uh sense I I mean
between Bernard and Luke Lucas here
because I think that it depends on your
aim uh in in body fluids the shallow
program is can give you a good
temperature measurement
but I mean of course the deeper the
better but I mean in order to validate
something in a clinical sense it's very
difficult to validate a profile so you
need to sort of boil it down to some
type of sort of robust measurement that
you can really rely on in the clinical
terms yeah
yeah yeah so I think I mean the Baseline
we can all agree on is that it all
depends on the questions of course and
one has to have a good question and that
determines also perhaps your approach um
so I I guess we don't necessarily sort
of have to
uh dwell on that subject
um in particular because it and it's
going to be very very variable but so I
was what I was trying to sort of tease
out is actually your experience to some
of these questions so okay what I've
heard is model systems go deep so that
you can understand it
um I guess the peptidome perspective is
a particular one again of course no of
course and I mean I think we we are so
what what my experience is is that
sometimes so when we do these
experiments and we are for example
expecting a certain MHC Associated
peplet that we know should be should be
in the data we don't see it and then the
question comes you know is it is it
because it's too low abundant is it
because we just we don't have enough
time we have no no not good enough
fractionation of the sample and there's
there's certainly a lot of space still
to improve our data sets from this side
and I just wanted to to kind of comment
on on the previous discussion in in a
way that I think ultimately you know it
cannot hurt to have deep proteomics data
Maybe maybe what you want to see uh is
is you know the most abundant protein
but you will still see that despite
having a much broader view on the sample
and and therefore I think and
specifically from my perspective with
immunopeptideomics is um you know
sensitivity it's still an issue and and
we can't work with biopsy if we could
work with biopsies we could do so much
more and we could we could we could it
would be amazing we could look at before
after therapy these are things that we
are at the moment in we were in humans
cannot do so we have to do it in my mice
model for example in most models but
I don't think that's very relevant
because the immune system is very
different the MHC Associated peptides
are very different so we are really
really dependent on that technology
boost and and getting more out of the
sample at least yeah
so Nicola maybe I'll
um I'll push on this a little bit so
I I do quite a bit of them you know
peptidomics and I do it on biopsies but
the difference is
I'm not searching for low low abundance
you know neoantigens maybe right so
people think about immunopeptidomics
differently what they're looking for how
deep they're looking for it if you want
to look for some things you need a
bucket of material for other things
maybe you can glaze over and get a
couple thousand peptides and still learn
what you'll want to learn so it kind of
goes back to like what I guess Bernard
said like what do you want to get what
do you want to get out of your sample
and yeah you know maybe in some cases we
we can get away with less we just don't
go as deep and
do we have the tools to figure out what
that information means you know I think
from my perspective I think that's where
the field is
um
still has Room to Grow is in learning to
interpret whatever data we get and what
is it
so uh Jazzy what's the industry
perspective on having run large
biomarker studies for example
protein-based what turned out to be
important
for you in the end
it was a little bit bad connection could
you please repeat yeah I wanted to get
your sort of perspective from from a
Pharma slash industry angle where you
have been involved in running large
clinical sort of biomarker studies
and from a perspective what turned out
to be really important in the end other
than the quality of the sample and what
have you but analytically to the
question how how far did one have to go
in order to find those markers
um that that you were investigating at
the time or is that a complete wrong
angle because you've nominated these
guys before and then just set up essays
that would specifically look for those
no I think that it was important I mean
in lung cancer in in Asia when eraser
was introduced as a first targeted drug
uh I really think that proteomics was
important so we could sort of
move with the clinical study or the
clinical centers there were 53 of them
and we could actually
have data that could help I don't say it
was the determinator but it actually did
help together with genomics and clinical
scientists also the direction to take
and the question that was the the major
one was uh to select I mean to find
responders from non-responders
and that was linked to the heterogeneity
of the disease presentation in the
tumors it turned out in the end so this
is where the whole egfr signaling uh
story and and the details of that and I
just saw
um uh Lauren that actually laufenbach he
was on that during those couple of years
where we did some work together so it
was kind of exciting to see on board
here as a young scientist but I would
like to pose another thing about and
that is that I I actually believe that
um
uh after 20 years in Pharma I would say
the the impact of in vitro work we've
done it did not pay back
and I don't see that in in Academia
either I mean you need some yes animal
studies uh somewhat better for for let's
say Milestone achievement proofs for for
drugs to move forward but I think that's
a that's a challenge too so I would like
to see more of of let's say clinical
protein work being done in indices areas
with patients and there's much more
value
and the heterogeneity still I think is a
major challenge you know why do we get
these relapse and these drugs that are
introduced into the market I mean many
of those actually do not give the
patient so much more
but there's an enormous pricing in this
and and uh
so I think there's a rule for a lot for
us this is actually a battle in between
the immune system and the cancer cells
ability to to to trick us out and I
think these mechanistic miles now we
just need to get our heads around how
how that works and that is of course
different in different cancer diseases
sure okay
um so maybe we'll take a question from
our audience it is quite different from
what we've been discussing so far but
still it's a good question not sure we
have
necessarily the right panelists on here
but I read the question so is mass
spectrometry Imaging still valuable for
searching protein biomarkers in tumors
for example by comparing proteins
distributed in tumors and healthy
tissues
sort of in a different way any
experience
with this I mean this was a very strong
wave many years ago by now that the
ability to generate pictures from
tissues by mass spectrometry and then
getting M of that values of markers that
are or yeah that that show differences
between things so what's the current
state of play here my my uh sort of I'm
we're not into this but when I look
around us it seems that all the major
pathology University pathology Labs have
it and they do it so I guess um they are
learning something from it but maybe if
one of you has a more informed opinion
about this
no but I would say that the the
interesting
thing
is to actually
connect the bulk proteomics and bulk
analyzes to the the tissue architecture
and I mean if that connection can be
done it's interesting I mean but what I
think has evolved a lot in in recent
years is this sort of targeted tissue
analysis of panels of
um the mass cytometry based analysis and
this uh all eco-coupled antibodies in
the in the tissue distribution and also
this tube has transcriptomics
I don't uh where I've seen the tissue
Mass spectratory Imaging making uh
imprint is actually the distribution of
the drug metabolites and Drug
distribution in the tissue and and that
type of targeting metabolite analysis I
think that the pro term side is
[Music]
um
is suffering of the problems with the
ionization from different uh background
issues
okay
well okay we'll let that stand for the
moment then um
so now I'm getting questions rolling in
so you can Lauren say something while
I'm reviewing more of your questions
um Boris group and in collaboration with
um Natalie agar has done some some cool
work
um kind of like was just mentioned
looking at drug distributions and
correlating that with
um you know phosphorylation signatures
or protein expression signatures and you
know trying to understand how you can
predict drug distribution
um from just doing the the proteomics
um and that it has been interesting so I
think there's a nice marriage between
the two the two
um types of analyzes if you have you
know access and expertise in both
um I can also imagine that it would be
really interesting for for the
assessment of tumor heterogeneity and
and to see you know what what are the
expression profiles in different areas
of the tumor and then comparing that as
well with with treatment outcomes but I
I don't have direct experience with such
data
okay
um we have another question that circles
back to the very very first thing that
uh JoJo was saying that um what is our
opinion about the standardization of
sample preparation in pre-clinic sorry
pre-analytical variables and how that
affects what comes out at the back end
um
don't we think that the lack of
standardization has hindered the
discovery of biomarkers or understand
mechanism of disease
question mark
maybe my previous Prelude is that I've
not yet met anyone who really likes to
work on standardization because it's
just a hard uphill battle
um but that is right but they decide I
mean the question is don't we think it's
important or how important is it again
by ideally driven by experience perhaps
more so than by what we think
yeah but I mean can I just comment on
that that I think that the the single
most uh important thing that has
hindered the biomarker discovery and and
our understanding
is uh ability to generate data on
hundreds of samples
I mean what uh really surprises me is
that um that even with the DIA based
proteomics and tumor proteomics
uh people run
um 10 samples 20 samples 40 samples
and I mean this is not going to give you
uh because I mean the noise of the
pre-analytical variation is going to
overrule the the biomarker signal but if
you run 500 samples then
um
you can you can tease out maybe the
signal there so I mean I think that's uh
the it's a numbers game here I mean like
Nicola said go deeper and go bigger with
the numbers
yeah because the other thing is that you
cannot really control the sampling I
mean it's also of course very good but
this has been this is not a proteome
specific uh thing the clinical
laboratories have been standardizing the
sample flows last hundred years we can
step into that the solution is running
more uh and running deeper
so well what again what what my
pathology people tell me is that it's
hard enough to standardize in one
Pathology Lab it's almost impossible to
do it between two pathology Labs uh
which is actually a big obstacle to
running multi-center
studies again Georgia might have
something important to say about having
pulled together many many centers and I
guess it depends on the amplitude of the
signal that you have in your system if
if it's big then it's not so hard and if
it's tiny then it's going to be
impossible and one other angle to this
is when we look at at least if we stick
to cancer we're seeing more and more
clinical trials that are not big and and
they're even Trials of n equals one so
how does one respond to that I mean
there are baskets and baskets of baskets
and so all reflecting sort of the
reality that the Patient to Patient
heterogeneity
is big or can be very large and the
molecular mechanism driving their
diseases can be big and we and more get
more and more approached by clinicians
who say genomics is great for certain
entities but many cancers are
genomically or mutationally So Silent
that we don't learn anything from this
um so the question comes up is it really
a numbers game
and is it a numbers game of patients or
is the numbers game of proteins
or or yet another level post translation
of vegetations what have you
oh that's a tough one I know but but
again I mean there is no not one
solution but not to everything sure so I
I agree with with Jana I think that the
N number uh needs to be high
otherwise you will not be able to take
some conclusions you cannot do it in all
disease areas I I do understand however
however I do think it's important I mean
I think that we have reached a point now
where you actually can understand
uh for instance in melanoma we we just
publishing a paper on 510 tumor samples
and here we believe that we have
covering like 95 percent plus of of all
proteins expressed and they have been
characterized fully in in the the tumor
histopathology
so so I think that a lot of the the the
groups that I think still have a weak
point is that you do not know too much
of the sample origin and and you move in
with heavy instrumentation and big
groups and everything but you if you ask
three questions on on sort of the
details of of of where it comes from and
and did if you have multi-centered study
uh all the prep steps similar or the
same I mean otherwise you have different
fractions from this from the patient
coming out right so what we have done in
these five centers that we collaborate
with globally is to develop the
protocols
and then the protocols has been sent
over we built up the the workflow I
bought all this
everything to have the same and then we
have real-time collaborative effort in a
database so you can actually in real
time see uh What patients are moving and
how many and what did they do what did
it not do and to be honest on a
pathology side I mean we are still
learning so I I think both the pathology
teams as as they are I mean there is a
massive one at saml WISE and they are
really good but but I think we still
have a lot to learn
so I'm I'm maybe I'm jumping in maybe
with a question again from our audience
uh and one person is asking outside the
mass spec based proteomics box so what
about other alternative and kind of
Novel Technologies such as Soma logic or
Nano Mosaic and and these things
um
to where do they sit
any experience with any
non-muspect-based proteomics things we
don't I don't have any
link based methods uh in parallel
which is uh antibody based coupled to
The Rolling Circle amplification so DNA
based detection couple to the antibodies
and I think
the
the the question theory is that I mean
or our experience there is that as soon
as you go into the antibody-based
methods whether it's Multiplex
immunohistochemistry or site of based or
o-link based
uh you always find 30 of the signals
with your protests that don't agree with
the mass spectrometry
and I think that's uh even in all link
where you have the two antibodies
detecting the target it's uh it's a
problem with the cross reactivity and
you're always limited on the on the
ability to pinpoint what what do you see
what protein form you see
so so I think that the the antibody
based and high throughput validation
methods are extremely interesting and
they form a very good uh combination
with the mass spectrometry thing but I I
do actually invest a big hope that we
can solve lots of these problems with
the mass spectrometry because it offers
an uh
uh straightforward uh way to detect a
particular peptide with a high accuracy
in a particular proton
and as soon as you change the media in
in or background in antibody-based
methods you need to do a very cumbersome
validation of all your markers
but they they are actually I mean the
whole Link's new system for example and
a few other these Multiplex systems are
very good and I think that the the
combination of the the analyzing the
tissue distribution of proteins and
architecture and the cell type
specificity and the Single Cell analysis
is something that we can combine
cleverly with the Mass Spectrum to based
proteomics but I think that the mass
spec is definitely a very strong part of
the future
okay
right I mean we I mean I'm looking at
the
clock we we still have quite some time
but I want to sort of bring in again the
the title of our session which is
maximizing the use of proteomic data so
we've been covering a couple of
important points it has been outlined
that getting good quality sample is key
and of course
um but that's not where it stops that's
kind of where it starts so
question to the group what we what do we
all think that the current main
obstacles for not generating data is but
maximizing the use of that data is it
that the machines
capture only a fraction of what we want
to see or is the software only telling
us a fraction of what's in there or is
there actually already far too much
information that we can't wrap our heads
around anyway and we would rather see
less or and we could just continue that
list of possibilities
and again it will be a very graded
answer depending on from which angle you
want to take a look at this but
generating data I would put out as a
thesis generated proteomic data isn't
that hard anymore and we could debate
how deep is deep enough and what have
you but it can be done it can be done
pretty efficiently we could we could
throw a lot of bad samples at it and
still get lots of data so that Machinery
let's see is I'd say not a
um at least far better than whatever we
had 10 years ago let it alone 15 years
ago and and what we're going to have in
five years maybe much better yet still
but um so what so let's say we have a
lot of data already so what is stopping
us or what is sort of limiting in terms
of really maximizing the use of that
what do you think
I mean maybe maybe we can we can bring
in
um the term Benchmark a little bit
because I think for from so from from
work that we've done it's always kind of
difficult so you work with for example a
foreign data set and
um and you realize you know for
Discovery rates are high so what's
what's going on and um you notice okay
well you know there's a shift in in
pre-cursor mass and the instrument
wasn't calibrated properly so I think
that's a major problem if you want to
kind of include external Mass
spectrometry data and use it again
um for maybe inclusion in your in your
in in your you know in what you're
interested in and and also I think
what I think is very important is
um a really correct uh description of
the controls that were used so you know
if you have a well-controlled experiment
you can you can you could make a really
large cohort study by just having 20
individual studies that were all well
controlled and you can look at
differences in all of them and then you
know combine that together and that kind
of
um is is from from our previous
discussion uh again important you know
do we need larger cohorts polar codes I
think yeah controls are really really
relevant uh here and also instrument
Benchmark to have to have control over
the quality of the data
I mean these two aspects
maybe I can flick in on other aspect
there that Nikola already took up
earlier and I I think that that's
looking at your data in different angles
for example uh in the immuno proteomics
I mean you can look at the same data uh
in terms of uh Neo antigens and then you
can look at the same data in the tumor
uh proton profile what is the immune
State what is the immune phenotype of
that I mean is there interferonal
factivation that is coupled to certain
neandigens and then go further and layer
your proteomics data with a genomics
data with a protogenomic search of the
neuro antigens and immunomodulators and
so on maybe transcriptomics maybe add
kinase activation with some kind of uh
uh kinase speed data and so on so I
think that we should really anchor our
proteomics data into the other data
layers also clinical data like yoga was
saying and a pathological beta because
it actually gives a molecular phenotype
data and we we only uh often use the
data in in two limited ways and not
layer it with other important data sets
and look at it both from the targeted
angle and as a representation of the of
the systems biology state
yeah I think actually talking about
layers that's that's a very good point
and I think even within proteomics there
are various layers such as protein
abundance ptms protein interactions
structural changes that by now you can
actually look at with various
technologies that I think
and I think this is mostly just at the
start so looking at protein interactions
looking at structural changes that has
just yet started and I think there's
actually still quite a lot of potential
to combining all these layers of
information even Within proteomics
yeah I mean maximizing the use could of
course mean different things to
different people I mean if Nikola would
be able to get a
an immune peptide ID from every mfms
Spectrum she generates she would
probably be extremely happy because they
are so low abundance that any every
every new extra peptide kind of helps if
you are hunting Neo antigens let's say
whereas our experience also with working
with industry often is they they
completely overwhelmed by a data Matrix
that has maybe a hundred experiments and
then 10 000 lines with protein
expression values and then they look at
you and say oh give me less
um so and and that's a sort of
maximizing use of data could have very
different sort of views right so and I
don't know how often you get confronted
with oh this is too much give me less
and so then the question sort of goes
towards how do we extract interesting
information
um from data and then the next level of
information of course is knowing
something what what that means and then
the next level on top of that that this
knowledge actually has some utility
um and and there's there's orders of
magnitude of sort of amounts of data in
between raw data is a plenty often
information not so much knowledge very
little utility ouch Maybe none
so what does it mean for you
maximizing the use of data
the vendors are gonna the vendors are
very good at either giving us
more stuff it's of a longer list or more
sensitivity on fewer things or maybe
with great technology getting both at
the same time but then that massively
sort of shifts the attention to looking
at this data and and trying to find
something that's interesting
well I mean I I've shown in my in my
talk today I mean basically if we
analyze a data set we can have a certain
result and then
um I showed you how if we then do
transcriptomics analysis and we do the
normal assembly of transcripts and we
actually find out specifically you know
sequences that we're interested in
um and we put those into our databases
then we can then we can really uh
identify novel things in our data sets
and I think that's
that's maybe really important in that
complex context that the more we we look
at the layers and and and try and get
our best the best proteomics data but
then match it up with a tailored
database
um coming from genomics information you
know that really refines the data and we
didn't see we didn't see viral antigens
in these in these cervical tumor
um tumor lines
um and and until we we sequence the
viral transcripts and then had the
correct sequences in the database so
there's there's that layer of
information that helps to refine the
data and that's not always available but
that should maybe be a consideration in
this context
that integration of data can really
refine our our view on the data and then
fish out the relevant bits that are
otherwise maybe not visible
okay but I also think that we have great
uh opportunity now with the data
repositories uh that are I mean and some
knowledge in the protomix data and I
mean uh
many of you showed that already in your
in your talks and I think that we have
also been most successful
when you sort of you start by a
hypothesis and your own data and your
sample collection and then you when you
start this generate the systems uh level
data you actually build the new
hypothesis
uh by looking at your system level data
but then going iteratively to a
hypothesis testing uh and back to the
building the hypothesis and in the
hypothesis testing part the there we
hover all kinds of proteomics data from
the public domain to test if our
hypothesis is actually valid by other
people's data set proteomics data set
and that's a great luck actually that we
don't have these big data sets so very
often we need to convert our proteomics
hypothesis to the transcriptomics
hypothesis and test the transcriptomics
databases because we don't really have
enough public domain products data but I
mean I think that the
we will actually the the data sharing
and the deposition and uh will actually
make your own data also more useful
okay yeah that's uh clearly one of the
hopes of
forcing everyone to put their data in an
accessible place that this could be
re-utilized by by others
um and in order to sort of bring that to
a new level
um what is your current what is your
view on sort of data standards and
things I I know it's another area where
quite a few people are spending a lot of
time
an effort on getting this moving forward
but at the same time it has also been a
very hard road to travel
um and many standards that have sort of
have come and gone
um with knowing what you know today and
you're using external data is it do you
find that this is actually important or
not so important or are you
opportunistic and say if I've
if I collect my data on a platform from
Bender a I'm going to just look at data
from the same vendor platform and not
worry about any of the other great data
sets out there or
are you trying to actually reprocess
then other vendors sort of formats to to
to try and integrate it with yours I
mean you probably all know that these
are they are great efforts and have been
going on for 15 years in our field of
trying to standardize data formats and
um and and it hasn't really I mean there
are these standards but I can't say that
they are universally followed
is it important or not important
I think it's very important I mean from
my perspective because there is a bias
obviously you you want to go with what
you are familiar with and because there
isn't the standards
um applied it's very difficult to
yeah to include data from from different
vendors let's at least from my
experience or my opinion
yeah I don't know I would say that uh
that it doesn't really matter in many
cases because you have what you have uh
I mean what you do I think what is
important is to make
the raw data available and have a
thorough metadata Associated to it I
mean that is because
you can uh I think that when we venture
towards the clinical protomix we need to
standardize a lot because uh then we but
then it's a completely different
quantitative biology and biomarker
questions but many of these uh like for
example the new antigen discovery that
we also do we'll just supplement our new
antigens to the database and search the
raw data again and see if we can find
them so it doesn't really matter and I
mean if it's
shallow data we we realized anyway how
shallow it is so we know what the
expectation is and if it's deep data we
see that when we research so I think
that the important thing is to to
deposit the data with the metadata that
we can actually use
uh because I mean it's in it's really
difficult in the research Community to
standardize everybody has their own
fractionation and uh tweak the
instruments but I have to say that the
the
industry the mass spectatory industry
with these few instruments that are
widely used has really helped our uh
uh course of using the and sharing the
data because I think that we are
familiar with the data types uh so so I
think it's um
I think uh
we it's difficult to expect uh
huge standardization okay we have four
minutes I'm reminded that our session is
almost over so maybe we have a sort of a
final round of a few statements just be
it Visionary or a cry for help or so in
the sense that what do you think we're
going to have achieved in 10 years from
now as a cancer proteomics field what's
sort of your your
sort of deepest wish you would like to
see come through within a 10 year time
frame and
Lauren Lauren start I'm going to ask
every one of you now Lauren well I guess
what I would say is I think in 10 years
it would be cool if we'd be able to in
the clinic generate some brand of
proteomic data whether it's expression
profiling signaling immunopeptidomics
and be able to translate that
information into something
um usable within a time frame that that
can help people and have that be a
widespread a widespread use 10 years
might be optimistic but
um that's that's that's what I'd love to
see okay great Nicola
well I I'd love to see the first
antigens we've discovered
in tumors to be in the First Nations I
mean the medication developed
on the basis of those antigens and so I
think 10 years from now I I hope to see
how how these Therapeutics work in
people okay yeah
well I I'm very optimistic I think that
the problem is it's going to be a
crucial part of selecting combination
treatments in cancer
I think that we need to uh and I think
that it's going to be in many ways I
think that we are going to have this
targeted programming panels of the large
fund on here targeted programs panels uh
going on I think we are going to have
this uh phosphor panels that the Lauren
and Company were using uh in in clinical
routine
uh I think we are we are doing that in
the genomics and the step to the
proteomics is not huge okay Lucas
yeah I think we will see a lot of
progress in terms of precision medicine
in the next 10 years so
proteomics will help to stratify
patients because in cancer heterogeneity
is so important and I think
proteomics can contribute a lot to to
find some groups of cancers and find the
right treatments for those for those
subgroups of cancers
all right then Jersey
okay well so when you look the cancer
patient in the eye every day you know
what I hope for is that in 10 years to
be able to understand more about the
mechanism of metastasis development and
use that for new drug development
right I mean I couldn't agree more this
is often most of the time what in the
end these patients succumbed to so uh
thank you for your your time which has
been one and a half hours for us I mean
life one hour half an hour chatting
before that it's a great time commitment
you made so thanks for joining this
round table I hope the audience
um will have gotten something out of it
uh perhaps I don't know if that's
technically possible that the audience
could give a big hand to the panelists I
certainly do so thank you very much for
your time and I hope to see all of you
very soon again in person and not just
on screens thank you very much and
goodbye
thank you bye-bye thanks everybody